drapeau canadien en main et faisant
sonner leurs klaxons des milliers de
manifestants et de camionneurs se sont
rassemblés ce samedi dans les rues de
toronto cette contestation partie d'un
mouvement de camionneurs dans l'ouest du
pays est venu de la ville voisine ottawa
certains chauffeurs ont parcouru des
milliers de kilomètres
tous refusent les nouvelles mesures
sanitaires notamment l'obligation
vaccinale
je pense que nous devrions tous être des
personnes libres je ne veux pas vivre
dans un pays communiste les gens
devraient être en mesure de faire leurs
propres choix de se faire vacciner ou
non et de ne pas perdre leur emploi leur
maison ou leur revenu à cause de la
vaccination
dès vendredi certaines routes du centre
ville ont été fermées par la police pour
minimiser les perturbations qui
pourraient affecter les hôpitaux mais le
mouvement de contestation se répand
depuis ce week-end dans plusieurs autres
villes du pays à québec
malgré un froid glacial
des dizaines de manifestants se sont par
exemple rassemblés le long des axes
routiers agitant des drapeaux canadiens
et des pancartes contre le gouvernement
nous sommes nés au canada c'est un pays
libéral nous ne sommes pas en chine
nous ne sommes pas à cuba c'est un pays
libre nous avons nous sommes censés
avoir une démocratie en place
mais à ottawa des centaines d'habitants
excédés par les blocages se sont aussi
rassemblés pour faire face à la
manifestation des camionneurs et
retrouver leur tranquillité
nous avons besoin que les klaxons
s'arrête ces camions bloquent les
intersections la police ne peut pas
faire son travail et en voyant comme la
police a répondu aux manifestations
précédentes
le fait qu'ils n'agissent pas maintenant
signifie qu'ils sont très complices
j'ai eu un problème avec les mauvais
acteurs ces manifestants se sentent
lésés et au canada nous donnons du tort
aux gens qui se sentent lésés nous leur
donnons une voix
je ne serai jamais en désaccord avec le
fait de leur donner cette voie mais je
ne suis pas d'accord avec cette
intimidation et les actions qui perturbe
la vie des gens de la ville c'est ce qui
me pose problème
les autorités canadiennes s'intéresse
maintenant à ceux qui financent et
permettent cette démonstration illégale
et nuisible selon les propos du chef de
la police d'ottawa
[Musique]